question de rapidité si vous voulez
faire votre pain il vous faut 4
ingrédients essentiels remet dans vos
souvenirs vous avez tous fait ça pendant
le confinement oh celle le vin et
en tout cas les buzzers marchent à la
perfection ça je peux vous dire puisque
les deux appuis depuis à peu près 1992
[Musique]
pas de limite
le niveau de diplôme jouerait sur la
libido selon une étude voilà plus les
Françaises et les Français ont un niveau
de diplôme élevé plus le sexe est
important pour eux et ce dont l'occasion
pour moi de rappeler au ménagères de
moins de 50 ans ainsi qu'à Valérie
Maurice que je suis bac + 5 ma petite
dame calmez-vous calmez-vous calmez-vous
chaque règle à son exception
je veux dire la vérité non je dis au
téléspectateurs j'ai revu les images je
pense que c'est l'année où j'ai été le
plus beau gosse
le plus modeste
67% des femmes et 39% des hommes ne se
sentent pas à l'aise lorsqu'ils sont en
maillot de bain pourquoi vous me
regardez
je comprends très très bien
six femmes sur 10 voilà pour éviter ce
sentiment et bien on adopte des
comportements si femmes sur 10 se
déplacent en rentrant le ventre et un
homme sur deux a déjà enfilé en paréo ou
alors un vêtement un short pour ne pas
dévoiler des bouts de chair
bienvenue à la gare de Marivaux Bardin
[Musique]
tous les trains sont supprimés ce soir
pour que je retard et grève indéterminé
on apprend aussi dans cette dans cette
enquête de l'Ifop que plus de la moitié
de ceux qui se préparent au corps d'été
développe des troubles mentaux notamment
de l'anxiété tout cela malgré
l'acceptation des corps qui était prôné
dessus des années parce qu'elle fait des
années que les militants anti
grossophobie essaie de dire à coups de
podcasts dans des documentaires
notamment sur Arte essayez de
déculpabiliser toutes les personnes donc
en surpoids elle est incroyable c'est un
personnage extraordinaire à chaque fois
qu'on la reçoit quoi qu'il en soit elle
fait le show a fait le spectacle et
c'est aussi un cœur en or je voulais le
dire parce que tu es un amour de femme
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
si je le chante vous allez peut-être te
reconnaître l'avion l'avion l'avion ça
fait monter les yeux les femmes les
femmes les femmes ça fait lever leurs
enfants bref et ça se lit sur le visage
du président que lui il avait reconnu le
morceau ça fait plaisir à la maison je
mets la musique
ACDC des choses comme ça je mets à fond
parce que je dis mes voisins peuvent pas
se dire c'est la vieille qui est en
train d'écouter ça
il m'a presque la soixantaine elle
travaille dans un centre d'appel depuis
15 ans traduisait elle enchaîne chaque
jour quasiment sans pause des dizaines
d'appels avec des clients énervés et il
y a deux jours juste avant 13h alors
qu'elle est à son bureau elle fait une
crise cardiaque et s'effondre les
urgences arrivent vite mais ne
parviennent pas à la réanimer son
cadavre est recouvert d'un drap mais en
attendant l'expert judiciaire il n'est
pas déplacé il reste là par terre dans
les bureaux de l'entreprise et pourtant
autour quasiment tout le monde continue
de travailler
tu es quotidien alors
fais attention à ma sœur t'inquiète pas
ça va
ben je sais pas
un employé fini par demander s'il peut
rentrer chez lui réponse du manager non
il doit continuer à prendre des appels
les salariés sont finalement évacués
mais l'un d'entre eux raconte qu'en
revenant plus tard dans les locaux il a
trouvé 4 de ses collègues encore au
téléphone avec des clients à quelques
mètres du cadavre comme si de rien
n'était l'entreprise ni leur avoir
demandé de continuer à travailler mais
c'est pourtant ce que conclut les
premiers rapports sur l'incident en
train de parler de Michel Dequenne
celui-là il a failli emménager ici il y
a quelques mois et au dernier moment il
a changé d'avis qu'est-ce qui vous est
en rire tous les deux ah bah je disais
que si on est soi-même touché par la
mort on a intérêt en rire et puis si on
n'est pas touché par la mort on n'a pas
de raison pour en rire
alors puisque vous avez consulté les
fils de Coluche est-ce que vous avez
consulté Michel dructure qui
s'opposerait à de Morgan Stéphane j'ai
pas envie de dormir
pour que dans les jours on Vienne moi je
donne à qui veut donner pareil
là appelle Odon je croise Michel Drucker
et je raconte la blague et cela fait
marrer il m'a dit il y a pas de problème
quand j'ai livré la bande à France
Télévisions ils m'ont dit mais tu es sûr
que que Michel est d'accord pour ça je
suis pas sûr qu'ils avaient entièrement
confiance en moi bizarrement bizarrement
et donc parce que vous avez évoqué sa
mort là Michel les a appelé Michel a
appelé France Télévisions on peut
blaguer avec eux en disant je suis au
courant je suis d'accord voilà ils sont
comment les métalleux
très cool sans folie ils sont d'une
correction il y a des vieux qui sont
plus con que eux
oui moi
la force est elle avec lui le commandant
en chef de l'armée ukrainienne Valéry
zalujni s'est fait remarquer sur les
réseaux sociaux avec ce détail un patch
baby Yoda sur son gilet pare-balle le
personnage de l'univers Star Wars
apparaît sur des vidéos et photos de
zalujni visitant des positions de son
armée plusieurs internautes imaginent
déjà un nouveau grade militaire d'autres
s'amusent avec une inversion des rôles